yeah he knows where he stands um he's a
smart guy and he understands that was
comments made a long time ago prior to a
college football game and
the organization is fired up about josh
and
what he's going to do moving forward
that's cliff kingsbury head coach the
arizona cardinals with us yesterday
talking about josh rosen and look we
have broken down this whole josh rosen
versus kyler murray situation the
cardinals i think do need to assess
kyler murray and decide whether or not
he would be a significant upgrade over
rosen but until they decide that he is
they need to make it clear that rosen is
their guy because otherwise you
undermine rosen outside of the building
and more importantly inside of the
building you don't want there to be two
months of josh rosen kind of dangling by
a thread and the players to see that and
then if rosen is your guy those guys
have to follow him he's been undermined
he's been harmed by the fact that he's
been forced to sweat for two months so
kingsbury's comments to me the full
scope of the interview and you can see
it at profootballtalk.com the full scope
of the interview would suggest to me
that kingsbury is all in with rosen and
is saying the right thing yes right even
if he's not allowing with rose and he's
at least saying the right things about
being all in with rose yeah he he
definitely is uh and and to your point
you're right they have to dance a very
fine line in making sure yes if they
don't go the kyler murray route that
rosen is still you know the face of the
franchise you're the leader of the
offense if you're gonna try to create
culture in a building you know the one
thing you can't do is undermine
good players or high draft picks on your
team especially at the quarterback
position so that can be tough there but
at the same time i look at a steve kaim
and his comment there just right you
know he is right now sure
you know
uh hey i'm sure they're gonna play that
you understand how this this show works
we didn't play that yet no we haven't
played it yet that was that was a break
i i thought i was playing it right
before that was great
we're getting ready let's play that yeah
hey man if he's going to do it let's do
it you know what i really wasn't like
throw to the sound hey let's go to steve
keim and hear what he had to say it's
really quick
sasha wasn't our quarterback yeah he is
right now for sure
is josh rosen our quarterback he is
right now for sure so so much for the
plan yeah to support josh rose right and
and it's obvious what steve cahn was
saying there he is right now for sure it
sounds like what tom coughlin said about
blake bortles last week pretty much but
you know i think what you have to worry
about in these scenarios with like a
steve kaim and how he's saying it too
hey i know they're going to do their due
diligence on kyler murray they're
obviously going to study everybody at
every position but you know the way he
says that too
uh
that might scare some teams right
because now they go oh i mean maybe
they're not really sold on josh rosen
maybe they are maybe there's a team in
the top 10 that really does fancy a
kyler murray so now you drive up the
interest the cardinals and just in that
there alone can start to drive up the
trade uh value for their pick the number
one pick overall if they kind of leave
it in balance that yeah we might still
take this kyle murray so rosen is right
now right now he is so i think that was
a very smart planned comment right there
to kind of get the masses to think oh
they're not quite sold on rosen so they
might not really be but he'll be able to
sell that to the other side too a rosen
and go you know i got to play the the
the you know the tricks of the trade
here and try to get up the interest to
to help our team because we have a lot
of roster issues right but again you
potentially undermine him in the locker
room and you need to make sure that your
head coach eventually explains to
everyone what was going on here right
look we were never gonna
draft kyler murray josh rosen was always
our guy we said what we said because we
we wanted a team out there that was
interested in trading up for kyler
murray to think that calling the 49ers
at number two wasn't going to be good
enough they needed to go all the way to
number one and from that perspective it
does make sense because
for the same reason they need to
evaluate kylo murray they also need to
smoke out all the best trade
opportunities because then at the end of
the day you can make an informed
decision you you've done your work on
kyler murray that's right you've done
your work to get the best trade
opportunity out there and you're on the
clock now you you have unlimited time to
do all this there's no 10 minute window
no no you can spend the next two months
is it murray who's out there that would
want to trade what's better for us what
can we get for josh rosen and the danger
is if you start talking to teams about
what you could get for josh rosen that's
when you run the risk that someone runs
their mouth sure that the cardinals are
shopping josh road sure right but you
know what that would be if if if your
theory is accurate that's part of this
plan too it's not just steve kahn making
a six-second comment it is shopping josh
rosen because if i'm a team thinking
about trading up and i hear that they're
they're talking to people about what
they're going to do with rosen that's
when i take seriously the idea that they
may take murray yeah this is a it's
really a fascinating conversation in
like human psychology this whole thing
that's what i kind of like about this
because you know at the same time yes
you want to be careful but i don't you
don't want to anoint josh rosen as the
king of your franchise either he hasn't
earned that to this point as well does
cliff kingsbury think he fits exactly
perfect into his offense i'm sure he
does in a lot of ways but i'm sure he
looks at a kyler murray and goes wow you
know hey my offense i'm still getting
used to the nfl this kyler murray guy
might be able to bail me out of a lot of
instances when some of my college pass
schemes
might not be quite what i thought they
would be and now kyler murray can
scramble around and do everything like
that so you know again i think they have
to explain things to josh rosen don't be
too overly concerned to how he looks in
the locker room either if josh rosen at
the end of the day has to hear about
kyle or murray maybe going to arizona
and maybe being the guy there and he
starts to get down or not feel good
about it or you know feeling like you
know he's in the in the doghouse to a
degree then man maybe he's not the
quarterback because if you can't handle
a little struggle or you know a little
competition in the building and things
like that then maybe you're not the
right guy yeah because it gets a lot
harder when you're out on the field
exactly right you're going to have a lot
bigger obstacles in your career than
this you know coming forward i was in a
place with john gruden every year where
we were talking about drafting a
quarterback every year we were talking
about signing a free agent quarterback
every year and at one point you just
gotta go you know screw it i'm just
gonna come out here every day and work
hard and not worry about anything else
there is and be the best chris sims i
can be and see where it takes me from
there um so this is gonna be fun to
watch i do think kyler murray really
fits what a cliff kingsbury wants to do
and mike kyler murray is the best
quarterback in this draft it's just are
you going to be comfortable i i am i am
not moving off that he is the best
quarterback for me from what i've
studied at this point it's special the
only thing his only flaw that i saw on
film is when he takes a square hit there
was a few times where yeah he he gets up
slow and that scares me when a defensive
tackle swallows him up he disappears
like like a like a cartoon almost it's
very rare to see a quarterback with his
size and stature uh in the nfl as we
know and that's really what teams are
going to have to become comfortable with
at the end of the day because i think
everything else on film it checks the
boxes everything mike i was so
thoroughly shocked by how good he was as
a pure quarterback i i can't tell you
let alone just the athletic skills and
all that and this is where it becomes
not just a football decision for the
arizona cardinals look at where they
were a few years ago 2015 they made it
to the nfc championship game they were
in the process of becoming a national
brand something i never thought would
happen to the cardinals i mean not
exactly a nickname that inspires
intimidation a you know a mildly
perturbed bird on the side of their
helmet like this is not a team that
anyone is ever going to be following sea
to shining c they were starting to move
in that direction and we've seen over
the past 15 years when they have a good
quarterback right when it's kurt warner
right they can be competitive when it's
carson palmer they can be competitive
they had several lost years between
warner and palmer and now they're
migrating into potentially more lost
years with rosen and whoever else and
this is their chance i mean and i think
of the browns 2016 they could have had
carson wentz they traded
and they took miles garrett and then
they they traded out of the desean
watson spot
then they got their baker mayfield i
mean if the cardinals are learning from
other people's mistakes they may say you
know what
we got this new coach it's a new day
this quarterback fits and this
quarterback is going to inspire
far more than josh rosen did josh rosen
last year kind of a polarizing guy
this condomer i mean people can get
behind it people get excited about it
you can market kyle murray you
definitely can become a national brand
again and when you are in a division
where the rams look like they're going
to continue to be very good the seahawks
have russell wilson and they are good
the 49ers they can never keep jim
garoppolo healthy they could be very
good this is the kind of thing that you
may need
to make you competitive in that division
and if i'm the owner of that team yeah
it it isn't going to be all that hard
for me to get to the point where i say
you know what we're rolling the dice on
college
the
so be it right you can't be the guy who
missed on the next phenomenon yeah if
they feel that strongly and they do feel
like he's the next phenomenon i mean
they said they sit here and go through
this process and they go yeah we like
some of these dr you know pass rushers
and some of these guys that but man
we're still in love with kyle or murray
then they do they have to pull the
trigger and draft kylie murray that's
that's all there is to it because
they'll they'll kill themselves or drive
themselves crazy for the rest of their
lives realizing if they see kyle murray
running around football fields for some
other team just dicing up defenses uh
but at the same time what you're gonna
have to again become comfortable with is
hey we're talking about kyle murray he's
up to 206 pounds right you know is he
going to be 189 pounds in week 12 of the
season when he's worn out and he can't
lift you know weights all the time and
he's just physically beat up that way is
he going to lose a little speed in week
12 when he's been you know battered a
little bit and hit a little bit and then
all of a sudden you go wow well now he
has to completely play from the pocket
and you lose some of the the greatest
assets he has as a quarterback that's
where
teens are really going to have to feel
comfortable and do their due
diligence
but i'll say this much in games that i
watch like let's just say alabama in the
in the final four game
for the national championship against he
he was not out of place yes he's small
out there certainly but his ability to
see down the field in the pocket is much
better than i gave him credit for when i
was just you know tv scouting or
watching college football on a saturday
and speaking of kyle murray he's going
to get measured he's going to get
weighed and the hand size and i'm told
there's confidence in the murray camp
that it's going to be above nine and a
half inches okay that's good so we'll
see i will say when i shook his hand and
i am a i am an evaluator of bodies okay
you know me i like to look at legs and
button and when i shook his hand i did
not go
whoa this is a really small hand is that
what you did when you shook my hand yeah
you have a decent sized hand i i mean i
think i measured it once and it was like
my hands bigger than i thought it was
right yeah i believe that i mean and you
could spin the ball a little i taught
you a few things zion williamson wears
an 11 i wear a 12. what yeah
where is that eleven that's crazy maybe
that's why a shoe exploded well yeah i
mean mate you jammed 280 pounds into 11.
it's 11 that's not me
we're not ready for that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports